le rejet du vaccin d'astrazeneca dépasse
maintenant les frontières de l'europe
ce vendredi matin le premier ministre
thaïlandais devait recevoir une première
dose du vaccin anglo-suédois mais il a
finalement décidé de ne pas se présenter
au rendez vous les autorités sanitaires
ont décidé de suspendre le démarrage de
la campagne de vaccination
nous venons de reporter l'injection
prévue pour notre premier ministre parce
que nous avons reçu des informations d'
agences de presse selon lesquelles en
europe
quelques pays ont suspendu la
vaccination il s'agit donc pour nous de
nous assurer que nous avons bien
couverts tous les facteurs de sécurité
avant d'administrer ce vaccin à notre
dirigeant
les dates
c'est en effet en europe que tout a
commencé en l'espace de quelques jours
sept pays européens ont retiré du marché
les doses du vaccin d'astrazeneca lundi
l'autriche a lancé ccdh administrés en
l'eau du sérum britannique après le
décès d'une infirmière
la quadragénaire est morte à la suite de
graves troubles de coagulation apparue
peu après l'injection
l'estonie la lituanie la lettonie et le
luxembourg l'ont suivi dans cette
décision et l'italie vient de faire de
même en interdisant le lot en question
ce jeudi le danemark et l'islande puis
la norvège sont allé un peu plus loin en
suspendant complètement l'utilisation du
vaccin britannique décision prise après
avoir aussi constaté la formation de
caillots sanguins chez des personnes
vaccinées des réactions en chaîne qui
pousse les autorités du royaume uni à
prendre la parole publiquement
nous avons été clairs sur le fait que le
vaccin est à la fois sûr et efficace
lorsque les gens sont invités à se
présenter pour le recevoir
ils doivent le faire en toute confiance
de son côté l'agencé européenne du
médicament se veut aussi rassurante
les informations disponibles à ce jour
indiquent que le nombre de
thromboembolie chez les personnes
vaccinées n'est pas supérieur à celui
observé sur l'ensemble de la population
à son arrivée sur le marché
le vaccin astrazeneca s'est présenté à
tous les pays européens comme un moyen
d'accélérer les campagnes
vaccination en réunissant de qualité peu
coûteux et pouvant se conserver
facilement à la différence des vaccins
moderne avec pfizer
des caractéristiques qui ont parfois
fait oublier l'un de ses défauts une
efficacité évalué à seulement 70 %
contre plus de 90 pour ses concurrents
des limites auxquelles viennent
s'ajouter plusieurs critiques sur les
délais de livraison émises notamment par
la présidente de la commission
européenne au sol avant de lier face à
l'arrivée du vaccin johnson & johnson
validé ce jeudi par bruxelles les 27
membres pourraient d'autant plus être
tenté de revoir leurs contrats avec la
firme britannique